[MUSIC PLAYING]
NEAL MUELLER: Hi.
I'm Neal Mueller, on the
geographic expansion team.
We build the technical
infrastructure
that powers Google and
Google Cloud Platform.
This includes new
regions, points
of presence, solar
and wind farms,
and terrestrial and
submarine cable networks.
Today, I'm here to tell you
about our new amazing region
in Singapore.
It just opened.
The Singapore region
was built to service
Southeast Asia, which includes
Vietnam, Thailand, Indonesia,
Philippines, Malaysia, and
of course, Singapore itself.
This isn't our first
region in Asia.
We also have Taiwan and Tokyo.
Our global network
connects all of our regions
together all over the world,
and our 100 points of presence
together.
This global network
is the largest network
of any public cloud provider.
Now that I've told
you about the network,
let's talk about the
Singapore region itself.
For the first time
ever, GCP users
can process and store
data in Singapore.
And as you can see
from this list,
the services include
compute, big data, storage,
and networking.
You can find a whole lot more
detail at cloud.google.com
/about/locations.
In short, the new
Singapore region
has everything that you
need to build and scale.
And now, let's hear a few
words from our local team
in Singapore to learn
what this new region means
for local customers.
ANISH MALHOTRA: Hi.
I'm Anish.
I help customers migrate to
Google Cloud in Southeast Asia.
You're seeing a huge
demand for GCP customers,
like Carousel, Go-Jek, VPN,
and [? BWC, ?] to name a few.
I love working with Go-Jek.
We're using Google Cloud
infrastructure services
to run their hyper-local
transport service in Indonesia.
I also love working
with Carousel.
We're using BigQuery to
power the classified ad
business used by more than
half the people in Singapore.
The new Singapore
region means speed.
Our performance testing
of the Singapore region
shows 50% to 98%
reduction in latency
when serving customers
in Southeast Asia
as compared to any other
GCP region in Asia.
With the opening of
our Singapore region,
Google is your neighbor.
Right here, right next door.
NEAL MUELLER: That's right.
And as you just
heard, there's never
been a better time to get up
and running with Google Cloud
Platform in Southeast Asia.
We think GCP is the smart,
secure cloud that will
move your business forward.
And with our new
region in Singapore,
we're right next door.
We're excited to see
what you'll build
on top of the Singapore region.
And remember to check
out the Google Cloud
homepage for upcoming
summits that are near you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]